when translations go terribly wrong
example one google translate to fail the
town in Galicia Spain wanted to promote
its culinary festival among Spanish
speakers the annual festival celebrates
a green vegetable called the grello
when local officials employed Google
Translate to find the word for grello in
Castilian Spanish it generated clitoris
the town website promoted the clitoris
festival four months before the mistake
was finally spotted perhaps not
surprisingly there was greater interest
in the festival compared to previous
years example two Canali Italian to
English channels or canals in the 1800s
an Italian astronomer charted the
geographic features of Mars
he observed what he thought were
channels or Canali in Italian American
astronomer Percival Lowell interpreted
Canali as canals that had been
artificially constructed by Martians
Louis spent years mapping hundreds of
what he believed from Martian made
canals
thanks to this misunderstanding example
3 pardon my french
tiny players said to have attempted to
show off his language skills when
speaking to the French press Blair
intended to say that he'd always admired
the Prime Minister of France
Leonardo's ban he actually said
something along the lines of I have a
great desire for the Prime Minister in
many different positions
you